[Musik]
hallo lisa wie geht es dir was ist los
doch keine sorge immer geht es gut aber
nico hat ein problem er war auch am
flughafen er kommt aus spanien
ja genau er kommt aus spanien und er hat
ein problem seine tasche ist weg und er
spricht gut deutsch hat er papiere aus
was hast du einen pass
nein - pass ist in seiner tasche aber er
hat ein foto von seiner tante sie wohnt
auch hier in deutschland aber nico hat
die adresse nicht meine tante die hälse
bicycle schon seine tanz hat ein
geschäft ein paar abgestellt wir suchen
also eine adresse die frau anna baracke
okay dann kommt noch minikurze polizei
danke papa gerne bis später bis später
und vielleicht kann mein vater uns
helfen
er hilft die herbst
so passt gut lisa ich schaue immer noch
nicht der fall
[Musik]